- All right, let's
finish up with something
people all over social
media are talking about.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(crowd applauding)
I love the idea of siblings
looking out for one another.
And one Georgia woman wanted to help
her little brother out,
after his engagement broke off,
by selling the ring.
But when no one bid on social media
she decided to take a fresh approach.
She reposted the ad with a few edits.
It reads, "My super cute, super sweet
"amazing firefighter brothers loss
"can be a big win for you."
(crowd softly whooping)
But here's what got everyone's attention.
Here we go.
(crowd loudly whooping)
Yeah, yeah.
They wanted more than the ring, I think.
She also shared a few pictures
of her brother and his
firefighter friends.
(crowd whooping)
Yeah, exactly, what are you selling here?
This is like those ads, you know,
were we're like, oh it's about a ring.
(crowd laughing)
We have these siblings
on the line right now,
everybody say hi to Melissa and Patrick.
What's up y'all?
(crowd cheering)
- Hey Kelly.
- Hey.
(crowd applauding)
- Oh my gosh.
Melissa, how did you come up
with this approach for the ring?
You're awesome and should
get into marketing.
- I think I missed my
calling as a madam actually.
(crowd laughing)
(Kelly laughing)
Patrick was trying to
sell the blinking ring
and was unsuccessful,
so I thought I'd give it a shot.
It wasn't going well.
So one night after a
couple of glasses of wine
I decided to try to
make it a bit more spicy
and more click-worthy,
I guess you could say.
So I just put in the title,
changed the ad up a little bit,
put in the title, look
at the last picture.
And the last picture was of Patrick
and his very handsome friends
in their bathing suits at a party.
So even though that did get some clicks,
it also backfired on me
'cause then they all said
we're not interested in the ring
but we are in the firemen.
(all laughing)
- I love this.
Patrick, did you know that
your sister was doing this?
- So I had no idea
she really was gonna be
doing it to this extent
but I did know she was
gonna be trying to ring
at a different angle.
But yeah, we all thought it was hilarious
and we really just
wanted to sell the ring,
but it got a lot more likes and clicks
I guess 'cause of all the pictures on it.
- That's a good thing, man.
So a lot of women were asking Patrick,
if you were still
single, what is the word?
- No ma'am, I'm in a relationship now.
Met a girl about seven or eight months ago
and everything's going great now.
- I love that for you Patrick.
(crowd applauding)
We wish you all the happiness.
Thank you so much, Melissa, Patrick.
Good luck selling that ring.
I'm liking your post right now.
(crowd applauding)
- [Patrick] Thank you.
- And that's not all you two.
Our season one partner,
Pilot Pen makers of G2,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to honor truly unstoppable
people just like y'all.
So they're gonna be writing you a cheque
for a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(crowd cheering)
- What?
(Kelly laughing)
- Are you kidding me?
- No, you gotta take that new girl out
you know, for dinner or something,
I don't know, just saying.
And Melissa, you should get half.
- [Patrick] Absolutely.
- [Melissa] Oh my God.
(Kelly laughing)
- [Kelly] Alright.
- Thank you
- Thank you, guys.
Y'all have such a great 2023.
(crowd cheering)
(crowd applauding)
Thank you to all our guests today,
Salma Hayek, Tino, Dylan
Gilmer, Steven A. Smith,
Vincent, and Captain Bill Dell.
Y'all have a great day and if
it's not, try and change it.